now i know a lot of people do not like their belly
fat it doesn't look good it gets in the way but
you have to realize that this belly fat is the
tip of the iceberg there's a lot more going on
behind the scenes okay then that's what i'm
going to talk about so yes it doesn't look
good but let's talk about what's really happening
on the inside of your body for you to have a big
belly you first have to have a fatty liver now the
simple version of this is that your liver becomes
fatty because you're eating too many carbs and the
carbs are being converted into fat in the liver in
other places but the liver is only a certain size
there's only so much fat that you can cram in the
liver before it starts to overfill and spill over
into other organs outside the fat cell that's
called ectopic fat around the organs that's called
visceral fat so when you see people with a belly
you know they have a fatty liver and all this is
coming from a high carb diet as well as a person
eating many frequent meals you know having three
meals with two snacks that increases the insulin
and insulin is the storage hormone it will take
those carbohydrates and it turns the carbs into
fat inside your liver and around the organs now
typically what a person only sees is what's on
the outside they see their belly but they don't
associate any other problems at least initially i
mean their blood sugars are usually normal why
because the insulin is taking care of it the
insulin comes in there takes it out of the blood
so then we can maintain normal glucose levels
so we really don't see the high blood sugar
situation for at least a couple decades
and we don't even see the high insulin that's
doing all this conversion because the doctor never
tests your insulin levels if he or she did
they would find it would be very very high
and by the way there's a great test called
homa ir to detect your insulin levels and so
here we have this camouflage situation where the
high sugar is being camouflaged by the insulin
and the insulin is working really hard in the
background to store all this fat and so unless
you have an ultrasound in the liver you're
not going to detect that there is a fatty
liver all you're going to see is you have a gut
and then as the years go on as the liver becomes
fully filled with fat and now you start developing
insulin resistance so it takes more and more
insulin to lower this blood sugar until the point
where the body finally can no longer compensate
for all the sugar and then that's where the blood
sugar starts going up you become a pre-diabetic
and then an actual diabetic so the deeper
cause of this insulin resistance is really
a fatty liver because the liver can no
longer function and everything starts backing
up and you can pretty much summarize the fatty
liver to be aka also known as a high carb diet
and a lot of people are not connecting the
dots between the other symptoms that this high
blood glucose and insulin is creating like
fatigue frequent urination especially at night
like sleep apnea like a weakened immune system
like inflammation in the joints like arthritis
like cravings to sugar or metabolic syndrome which
is high blood pressure heart disease a fatty liver
and diabetes type 2. you see all of these things
and a belly fat is coming from the same thing
high carb diet high blood glucose and high insulin
so in summary i know your belly fat doesn't look
good but it's just the tip of the iceberg there's
a lot more going on beneath the scene and so if
you're interested in resolving this i have a
very good solution it's called healthy keto
intermittent fasting i put a link down below of
exactly what to do to get started so if you're
enjoying my content which i hope you are and
you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i'd really appreciate you
sharing your success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others